it appears that the universe
is bigger than it is older
how does that make sense oh oh yeah so
you're talking about the fact that we
can actually see stuff in our observable
universe that's located at a distance
that is farther than the speed of light
times the age of the universe yeah
naively you would say that the the you
know so you're right if the universe
were static
um if the universe came into existence
and you can conceive of this the
universe came into a big bang in a fixed
universe so the universe just started
off those galaxies were you know they
could be moving towards us away from us
who knows
um that you could say I can see a Galaxy
that's at a distance of only
13.8 billion years times the speed of
light that would be true but the fact
that the light is expanding along with
the expansion of the universe so imagine
there was some very distant past we were
near a Galaxy it's going to produce some
light and that Galaxy is going to be
moving away from us the light's going to
be getting more and more red shifted as
it's called it's going to be moving
farther and farther away from us as time
goes on there'll be some acceleration as
we get into the era of dark energy
energy
the light signals there'll be some cone
of acceptance if you will from which
which represents all the events that we
could have received information from we
can't currently communicate with that
Galaxy it sent us some light and now
it's moving away and it's set to some
light and because the space is also
dragging the photons with it if you like
the photons are being participating in
the expansion of the universe that's why
they're redshifting that we can see
things to out to where the universe
first began expanding not just when it
began existing and because the universe
has been expanding for 13.8 billion
years with no sign of slowing down yet
which is a huge uh surprise
serendipitous surprise that we can see
things approximately three times the age
of the universe away from us so we can
see it's called the age of the universe
15 billion years just to make the math
simple we see things at 45 billion light
years distance in that direction and we
see things at 45 billion light years in
that direction just turning our
telescopes 180 degrees away so that
means we see things that themselves are
or 90 billion light years away from each
other that's sort of the diameter of the
observable universe is there another
universe beyond that we don't know some
conjecture there's not only one there's
an infinite number of them how are you
emotionally okay with the fact that our
universe is expanding so like it's gonna
be like any Hall like with Alvey uh
singer no this is I grew up in the
Soviet Union
we watched propaganda I realized that
you did yes uh so there's a family Hall
is there some kind of what is this yes
movie with Woody Allen certainly
canceled but yeah but nevertheless back
when he was uh uh not canceled yet I
made a movie called Annie Hall in which
as a it says self-depiction he's like a
Larry David before Larry David Larry
David neurotic typical neurotic young
Jew he's in Brooklyn and he all of a
sudden tells his mother he's not doing
his homework anymore he refuses to do
his homework his mother says why because
because the universe is expanding and it
keeps on expanding uh everything will
rip apart and no will never have
anything in contact and everything is
meaningless I assume these are some of
the topics we're gonna get to uh and and
she goes what are you talking about
we're in Brooklyn Brooklyn is not
expanding uh and that's true Brooklyn is
not expanding the solar system is not
expanding though oftentimes they get
asked what is the universe expanding
into that's one of my favorite questions
uh what is it expanding into and I say
It's actually an easy question if you
think about it um you've seen your
friend Elon he goes on Space he's got a
rocket right what's outside of the
rocket if you take if you take his
bottle empty out this bottle take the
cap off it go outside the rocket you
know sip in some Tang
screw on the cover of it what's in there
is it empty
uh that's just semantics I guess uh yeah
no it's definitely not empty so you step
outside the rocket yeah you're in the
vacuum of space the quote-unquote vacuum
ups and there's no more liquid in it
there's no more liquid in it no it's
just just a container one cubic
centimeter let's make it simple one
cubic centimeter of uh box and you take
it out into space outside of the Falcon
whatever right yeah
um what's inside that box it's not empty
there's actually I'm gonna say this is
gonna set your friends there's 420
photons from the fusion of the light
elements that we call the cosmic
microwave background inside that box at
any second okay all right hold on a
second what
for 420 that's uh I've heard of that
number before all right let's it used to
be 69. but then they changed
wow physics works in mysterious ways and
the millimeter box is 69. what what are
we talking about here what uh what's
inside what's what's in the box I'm
gonna get it that's right let's think
outside the box no we're thinking inside
the way so if you have every cubic
centimeter of our observable universe is
suffused with heat left over from the
Big Bang
Dark Matter particles there's a little
ordinary matter in the universe
um uh in every cubic centimeter there's
some probability to find a proton a
cosmic ray an electron
Etc there's actually an awful lot of
neutrinos inside of that cubic
centimeter now just imagine how many
cubic centimeters there are in the
universe it's enormous that's why
there's enormous numbers of particles in
our universe it's a very rich universe
but now let's zoom in on that box so now
inside that box there might be you know
one let's let's say there might be one
ordinary matter like a proton or an
electron a baryon a lepton there might
be a couple some a couple hundred
neutrinos and there'll be a couple
hundred photons as I said 420.
what's between those guys
what's between the protons and the
neutrinos and the photons like just zoom
into the cubic Micron now like imagine
420 things inside a box this big it's
actually pretty empty like they're just
zipping around in there right so between
them there's a lot of empty space and
this is outside the kind of
physics-based models the fields and all
those kinds of things just like just
actually asking the question of like
what is this particle content in the
universe in every cubic centimeter of
the universe outside of the 420 so you
have the 420 420. you know that's some
Mass oh they have energy they don't
matter photons energy that's why they
don't bring suitcases you know that's
true right photons never bring suitcases
with you with them because they're
traveling light see I don't even get a
lesson that's corny dad jokes okay
you'll appreciate something no this is
pretty good it's just I'm laughing on
the insides what's in the box what's the
420 what's between the photons that's
what space is that's what the universe
is expanding into okay that's not so
that's that's the notebook yeah on which
the photons are written that's that's
beautiful but still uh yeah thank you uh
still
I I understand this but it's still
uncomfortable that if the uh the
universe is expanding that this thing is
expanding the the canvas is expanding
it's very strange because like if we're
just sitting there still I guess if
we're in Brooklyn nothing's expanding so
our cognition our under intuition about
the world is based on this local fact
that we don't get to experience
um
this kind of expansion yeah and that
intuition leads us astray but you know
that gravity is the weakest of the
so-called four fundamental forces
um and yet it has the longest range
pervasiveness gravity is you know we're
being pulled towards the Andromeda
galaxy at some enormous rate of speed
because of its massive counter
gravitational force to the force we
exert on it uh so gravity is enormously
a long range but incredibly weak and
because of that uh we can think about
these effects of expansion as the
relationship between the as you said the
no the the grid lines on the notebook
right gravity is a manifestation of the
interrelationship between those points
how far they are from each other and
those can change those Point distances
can change over time because of the
force of gravity so it's weak and what
and what we experience is gravity is the
changing of those trajectories from
being rectilinear to curvilinear that's
what we experience as gravity well you
have this analogy when you talk to Barry
barish about bowling ball and a
trampoline and that's almost right
because it's actually you have to
visualize that now in four dimensions
like wrapping a trampoline at every
Point around the object including on the
sides and you know it becomes very hard
to visualize so a lot of people use that
it's also fraught analogy because you're
using gravity like the notion of gravity
pulling something down to explain the
notion of gravity so it's a little
overburdening the analogy but okay so
you mentioned Barry barish wrote the
forward to your book yeah uh how do
gravitational waste fit into all this
how do they on the emotional level how
do they make you feel that they're just
uh moving space time yeah so
gravitational waves were the Nobel Prize
for gravitational waves Discovery the
first time you know it's this it was
discovered twice indirectly by two uh
men uh named hulson Taylor and that was
given my first year of graduate school
the I entered graduate school almost
they they announced these two guys one
and the guy who won it did the work that
would later win him the Nobel Prize when
he was my age is this in the 40s uh this
was no this is
gonna thank you I got it I got it you
know to a cosmologist age it means
nothing
um and to a tennis player not on Tinder
that's right all right awesome sorry
gravitational waves do fit in uh because
what we're trying to do now is use the
properties of gravitational waves the
analogous properties that they have to
photons that they travel at the speed of
light that they go through everything
they can go through everything and that
they're directly detectable we're using
them to try to confirm
if or if not inflation occurred
so did inflation the spark that ignited
the fusion of the elements in the early
part of the universe and the expansion
the initial expansion of the universe
did that take place there's only one way
that cosmologists believe we could ever
see that through the imprint of these
primordial gravitational waves not these
old you know newcomers that Barry
studies the ones that occur at a billion
light years away from us
a billion years ago but we're seeing
things that happen 13.82 billion years
ago during the inflationary epoch
however those we cannot build a ligo and
put it at the Big Bang so if you want to
measure let's say you have a the
old-time
um uh firecracker let's say there's a
firecracker and you want to see if it
went off in the building next door to
you you can't see it so you can't see
the imprint of it but you can hear it
and what we're trying to do is hear the
effect of gravitational waves from The
Big Bang not by using a camera or even
an interferometer like Barry used and
his colleagues but instead using the CMB
the light the primordial ancient fossils
of the universe the oldest light in the
universe we're going to use that as a
film quote unquote onto which
gravitational waves get exposed and hope
you can uh so what are the challenges
there to get enough accuracy to to for
the exposure so the the signal as I said
is um so there's 420 of these photons
per cubic centimeter and there's a lot
of cubic centimeters in the universe
however what we're looking for is not
the brightness of the photon how intense
it is we're not looking for its color
what wavelength it is we're looking for
what is polarization is and we'll go
there let me just ask are you serious
about the per cubic millimeter of 420 is
the number centimeter but uh uh cubic
centimeter 420 is the number I wonder if
you on noses and if he doesn't he will
truly enjoy this
yeah that's true